hey guys Greg here so earlier today I
put up a video explaining that I will be
doing a reaction to the Deadpool 2
teaser because I caught it before I
watch Logan they played it in the
theaters and there are comments a lot
came in they just wanted to know my
thoughts on it and I was like oh so
people actually really do stick around
for the review portion of the reaction
so we do I'm just kidding I knew that
part but yeah sorry for the lack of
uploads in the past couple days I've
been really busy yesterday we were up
really way late into the evening
shooting a sketch we're hoping we got to
complete the rest of it on Tuesday
hopefully have it up by next week
sometime but yeah we're shooting a
sketch talking my full-screen rap on the
phone a couple days ago so cube my
fingers crossed about something but
currently working on writing a pilot and
I finished the first draft normally not
so if we mention these kind of things
when you're writing a pilot and
especially if it hasn't been picked up
yet or anything but I know you guys are
very loving so hoping you guys can send
positive vibes because I wrote a pilot
that I show to a couple people and they
laughed a lot so I'm hoping that so if
it can actually happen with this pilot
anyway enough beating around the bush
and explaining I'm planning on being rep
back on regular uploads tomorrow morning
but in the meantime I will give my
thoughts on the Deadpool teaser that
came out and I feel like my thoughts and
experience will be different than what
you might have heard other people say on
the reaction portion because I did catch
this like I said before I watched Logan
and Logan if he I was doing a review of
it it's amazing amazing film and it was
really anticipating the movie hearing
all these things about how dark and you
know I just how immersive this film is
and so when we were watching the movie
though the I was in IMAX and I heard
it's like this for other theaters as
well the lights went off so everyone
thought the movie was about to start so
when the music cued and then you see the
man with the hoodie walking in the
streets are like okay is this the intro
to the Logan movie like this is
different than what I thought it was it
doesn't look that far into the future
that's just what I kept thinking what I
was watching it so when he took off the
hoodie
it felt like oh this is part of the
Logan movie everyone thought like this
was just a special clip for the Logan
movie the way it played in the theaters
didn't play the way how it is like Oh
Deadpool to teaser before Logan starts
it was like oh this is a little you know
a little a treat for the people who are
about to watch Logan who thought
Deadpool would not make some kind of
appearance because you see that Logan is
playing at the theater where Deadpool is
you know hiding in the phone booth and
trying to change really fast and
watching that with the crowd because the
crowd started applauding with Deadpool
showed up because no one was expecting
it we all thought the movie had started
so it was really exciting and when he
was changing into the soup that was so
[ __ ] hysterical because it goes back
to everything that Deadpool is all about
which is being like a semi spoof on the
superhero genre and I like how in the
end he didn't even save the guy's life
because if you watched the first
Deadpool movie he's not a superhero in
that movie he's just a guy on a revenge
mission really he has to rescue his
girlfriend at one point but that was
because he was you know going after the
bad guy whose name I can't recall at
this very moment but he he wasn't a
superhero by any means in that film so I
liked how they didn't turn a different
route where he's definitely a hero like
he still fails to save the guy who gets
shot and I saw that in the on the online
teaser that Ryan Reynolds released that
added a couple little differences the
one difference they had was a Stan Lee
cameo which is really cool because you
never see the Stan Lee cameo inside of a
trailer they always reserve that for the
movie so actually showing that in the
trailer was really funny it makes it
even more special because you're just
not expecting that so it's cool for
people who saw the trailer in the
theater and I was a great experience
because it looked like it was just a
part of the Logan movie but then when
they do a special thing for the online
teaser they show us that Stan Lee is in
this trailer which is really funny and
it's a closing bits and him not saving
the guy I just thought was a great way
to end it because it's just
or Deadpool in that moment and it does
get you excited it's because even the
trailer is a spoof of what a typical
trailers like what it says Deadpool 2
coming not soon enough that's how a lot
of people feel because I don't really
know what what the status is of the
movie right now I don't know if they
begin filming it I'm not exactly sure
where they're at in terms of the
production side of it we all know it's
coming we all know there's fill in the
casting process but yeah it was a great
way to get excited I was actually I
thought it was I thought it was better
than it wasn't a Deadpool 2 teaser I
thought it was better as like a prelude
leading into Logan because it's just so
totally jarring and shift it's just a
big shift as to what the Logan movie was
and you know there was all those things
about Ryan Reynolds tweeting that
there's no way Deadpool would be in the
Logan movie and other people part of
Logan were saying that Deadpool would
not be a part of it if he wouldn't fit
into the world so I thought it was cool
they had like a little tiny short film
of Deadpool like possibly on his way to
watch Logan and I thought it worked
better as that but as a Deadpool to
teaser and marketing and all that it
works as well
and I yeah I thought it was [ __ ]
hilarious so yeah you know you guys want
to hear my thoughts on it those are my
thoughts on it you can subscribe to the
reel rejects and thanks for tuning in